[Music]
they were born as Ordinary
People in a country that had never known
superheroes but one day they made a
choice or the choice was made for them
they were created and sworn to protect
their country the people who would never
know they
existed and when the Soviet Union fell
they remained behind in
[Music]
[Applause]
hiding
[Music]
but now evil is rising from the Shadows
of the past and they must
prepare for the final
battle they are our last
[Music]
hope
[Applause]
Moscow continue Army turned out to be
useless against the opposition forces
all attempts to stop it ended up with a
complete shutdown of any machinery